[Narrator] In one year, Disney
grossed over $2.7 billion
on "Avengers: Endgame"
and lost $170 million
on "Dark Phoenix" and other titles.
Turns out that in the 2010s,
not even bankable stars,
big marketing campaigns, or impressive CGI
can guarantee box office success.
We're going to take a look
at exactly what went wrong
with some of the most expensive
movie flops of the decade.
We've drawn up a list
using reported losses
from various media outlets.
"I am telling you, I am nobody."
[Narrator] "Jupiter Ascending."
The problem wasn't its
cast members Mila Kunis
and Channing Tatum, or
even the bizarre plot
of a cleaning lady with an
interplanetary inheritance.
It was overspending.
Directors the Wachowskis
had previously worked
with Studio 8 President Jeff Robinov
on the 1999 hit "The Matrix."
Robinov signed off on
casting and production design
and approved a huge
budget but left the studio
before the films' completion.
Fixing VFX issues prerelease
also added to the mix.
The movie opened to poor reviews,
and you can guess what happened next.
Name a film from the past decade featuring
anthropomorphised,
shape-shifting cars and trucks.
You're probably thinking
of a "Transformers" movie.
And there's a reason why you wouldn't know
the bomb "Monster Trucks,"
about a high-school senior
who discovers a creature
that feeds on oil.
Part of its failure
can be blamed on a lack
of on-screen talent, with Lucas Till
not providing much of an audience draw.
Also, in the age of
successful animated features,
targeting the kids market
with a live-action cars movie
that wasn't based on a
well-known Nickelodeon
or Hasbro property was a big risk.
"I like a good adventure."
"I'm looking for an adventure of my own."
[Narrator] This movie not
only changed its title months
before opening but also
underwent a change in director.
The movie was originally titled
"Jack the Giant Killer," which
suggests that it was planned
to be a grittier, edgier
retelling of Roald Dahl's
"Jack and the Beanstalk."
It also suffered from a
glut of similar releases.
It came out shortly after Jeremy Renner's
"Hansel & Gretel: Witch Hunters,"
another childlike fantasy flick.
"You didn't eat your broccoli."
"No broccoli, no TV."
[Narrator] Disney's animated feature sold
just $6.9 million
in tickets in its North
America opening weekend.
The plot line of a child
whose mother is taken away
from him was off-putting
for family audiences,
as was the unique animation style.
Producer Robert Zemeckis opted
for motion capture instead
of hand-drawn or Pixar
style of computer animation,
which led to comments about characters'
unnatural facial expressions
being terrifying.
"I long for the day that
I can come back for you"
"and explain everything."
[Narrator] By 2015,
starring in crowd pleasers
such as "Les Miserables"
and the "X-Men" franchise
had to put Hugh Jackman
in a bankable position
as a leading man.
But this adaptation of the classic
JM Barrie children's story
"Peter Pan" was criticized
for its simple plot and
pantomime performances.
After flopping with domestic audiences,
it went on to underperform
in the world's second-largest
film market: China.
Why?
It was released during a summer
of competitive family-friendly films,
such as French animated
feature "The Little Prince"
and Marvel's "Ant-Man."
Poor Hugh.
"It is inevitable."
[Narrator] "King Arthur:
Legend of the Sword"
was panned by critics
and made just $15 million
in its opening weekend.
This would be manageable for
a small-budget British movie,
but it was the exact opposite:
a Guy Ritchie-directed Warner Bros. flick
that cost millions.
So why did it tank so bad?
Idris Elba and Colin Farrell are rumored
to have turned down roles,
leaving Jude Law as the only A-lister.
And the story wasn't new.
Home audiences were already
familiar with an adaption
of the King Arthur legend
starring Clive Owen
which flopped in 2004.
Nowadays he's the internet's boyfriend.
"You're breathtaking."
[Narrator] But in 2013,
Keanu Reeves hadn't had a hit
since 2003's "The Matrix Revolutions."
Samurai fantasy-adventure
"47 Ronin" followed a string
of misses for the star,
such as "Constantine"
and "The Day the Earth Stood Still."
The movie's release date didn't help,
competing in a December
box office already packed
with "The Wolf of Wall Street,"
the "Hobbit" sequel, "American Hustle,"
"Saving Mr. Banks," and "Anchorman 2."
"Boy."
[Narrator] You'd need to
be a committed movie buff
to watch all those releases
over the festive period.
But we love you no matter what, Keanu.
Producer Peter Jackson of
"Lord of the Rings" fame taking
on a beloved seven-book
series by Philip Reeve sounds
like a license to print money.
But "Mortal Engines" took a crushingly low
$7.5 million across 3,103 theaters
at the domestic box office.
There were some obvious
reasons it flopped:
lack of star power, confusing narrative
about cannibalistic megacities,
and a woman with a mysterious destiny.
But what really crushed it
was the surprising box office smashes
of release-adjacent movies.
Clint Eastwood's "The
Mule" made $17.5 million
in its opening, one of the highest ever
for an Eastwood movie.
And family audiences were drawn
to "Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse,"
which piggybacked on the superhero trend.
"That's a copy."
[Narrator] There are
negative movie reviews,
and then there are the reviews
that "The Lone Ranger" got
on its opening weekend.
On paper, it sounded great:
reuniting Johnny Depp
with the team behind
"Pirates of the Caribbean"
and adding Armie Hammer,
who was a rising star thanks
to "The Social Network."
But critics called this 149-minute outing
too long and clunky.
The Guardian reported
that the filmmakers tried
to scale down the budget
after being spooked
by other modern Westerns bombing,
such as 2011's "Cowboys & Aliens."
But the budget soon spiraled again,
to the tune of $215 million.
Coming in at number one
is one of the biggest box office flops
of all time: Disney's "John Carter."
What really killed this
one was the trailers.
First, was a teaser
featuring a morose cover
of Arcade Fire's "My Body is a Cage,"
which featured no real action.
♪ From dancing with the one I love ♪
[Narrator] Further trailers
displayed the movie
as the most generic, boring blockbuster.
It had no real star power and
a glut of special effects.
Andrew Stanton, who also
directed "Finding Nemo"
and "Wall-E," reportedly
overrode Disney marketing execs
to have the final say on
the promotional material.
Which, let's be honest, was an error.
Even the "of Mars" was
ditched from the title.
The movie is based on Edgar
Rice Burroughs's 1917 story
"A Princess of Mars."
But just "John Carter" was as
vague as it was going to get.
Critics weren't kind to it either.
It went on to eventually
lose close to $224 million.
A little nod here to the also-rans,
including "Deepwater
Horizon," "How Do You Know,"
and "The Promise."
Did you go to see any of
these box office disasters?
Comment below.